So this is going to be a very different
type of video.
We're going to talk about time
management.
There are a million ways to do this,
but we're going to talk about the way
that I do it specifically.
I found one way that works really well
for me.
So I became self employed this last
January and one of the quickest things
that appeared to me is that it's a big
deal to know how to manage your time and
really you have a twofold problem.
One,
you have to create and prioritize your
goals and deadlines.
And on the other hand you have to have a
way to manage your time such that you
achieve those goals and deadlines in a
timely manner.
And here's a fair disclaimer.
My system might not work for you,
but the important thing is to take what
you find useful here,
apply it to whatever you do and just
leave the rest.
All right,
so let's get into it.
I do three main things.
I managed my time.
Number one,
I just have a planner.
You know this is pretty boiler plate
just to record any kind of trip
appointment.
Meaning something time sensitive that I
need to do.
There's not much else to say there.
Number two,
I block out my day into 15 minute
increments and fill them out as the day
goes.
I got this idea from the venture
capitalists,
Mike Jackson,
who's featured in the book.
So good they can't ignore you.
The reason for doing this is that I can
create a snapshot of what my day looked
like and I can see what I spent all my
time on.
So I usually fill in the sheet whenever
I complete a major task.
So if editing this video took me from
12:00
PM to 4:00
PM I'll just fill in those blocks all at
once and I use colors to designate that.
If you create your own version of this,
you're going to have to make your own
buckets that are relevant to your life.
So at the beginning of each day it looks
like this,
and by the end of it,
it looks like this.
And at this point I use a little macro
that I created to count up all the 15
minute increments so I can see that,
oh,
I spent,
you know,
this percent working out today.
I spent this percent reading,
et cetera.
Then we put in the date and hit this
button,
which saves the file into just this time
archive folder,
which I have,
which I'll show you right here.
What's really cool about this is that
after doing it for like four months now,
I can look back on any given day of
those four months and I can see exactly
what I was doing at any given time
during the day,
which is really cool and this brings us
full circle to number three and number
three.
I have review periods where I see how
much of my goals I achieved,
what my progress was and how much of my
week or month or whatever review period
I'm doing.
How much of that month was dedicated to
the right things,
how much of it could have been better
allocated somewhere else,
et cetera.
Basically I'm looking to see what I did
right and what I did wrong and what I
can achieve better next time.
This is a super underrated thing.
People think that just because your time
is in the past,
you should never look back.
You should absolutely look back.
All good time management system should
have some type of review system to see
how you actually did.
Anytime that you add in any extra
things,
some kind of goal,
some kind of,
you know you want to try running once a
week,
you have to know how you did and so
that's what this allows you to do.
So in this sample week you can see how
much I read,
how much I worked out,
how much time I wasted,
the percentage of my week that it all
took up.
And this is super powerful to let you
know where you can improve.
If you think,
oh man,
I spend more time on that than I
thought,
I'm going to move that over here,
you can do that.
So that's pretty much it.
This time management system has been
absolutely essential to me.
And I think if you're an entrepreneur or
you're somebody who is self employed or
just you know anybody who's very serious
about their time,
I think something like this would really
help you out.
So I'm going to leave my daily
spreadsheets as well as my review
spreadsheets in the links below with all
the macros already in them.
And I'm going to create a second video
to explain how to use them.
If your interested also,
if you want to learn more,
go check out David Allen's getting
things done.
Plenty of people have found him to be
awesome as well.
Okay,
that's all for now.
Be sure to comment.
If you have a system that already works
for you,
you can subscribe.
If you like the content,
check out the next video here where I
explained all my spreadsheets and thank
you guys so much for watching.
I will see you next week with another
coffee break.